and finally new rule if you're a
Democrat the conscience of your party
shouldn't be a Republican recent polls
show that Democrats have lost their
enthusiasm edge over Republicans and
it's no wonder they seem to have said
none of the bad habits that hurt them in
recent elections the identity politics
the purity testing the petty infighting
losing to trump should have jolted them
into a higher state of seriousness but
it did not twenty three candidates
that's not a primary that's an Avengers
movie
stop worrying about what your lame is
everyone's focused on their own
micro-targeted path from New Hampshire
to the Iron Throne they've all got their
eye on the Pizza Hut at the end of the
game but no one's playing well enough to
earn it I say it's time we Moneyball
this thing Democrats need a coach and
this year I have tried to be that coach
yes you do I do
you should go go that's who needs to
hear your message you got to get in the
bubble man it's about the audience
that's listening to it no I at least
they would hear the argument I will go
great for you I appeal yeah this has now
become an issue for all the Democrats
with many going on Fox but if I'm going
to be your coach oh wait I have a
whistle too
all these candidates have to remember
one thing
winning is a habit unfortunately so is
losing you know who said that Vince
Lombardi and he knew two things Hillary
Clinton did not how to win and where
Wisconsin is and that is rule number one
go where the votes are
get out of woke Vil for a day see what's
going on in mullet town you've already
got NPR go on Fox and you can't let
Trump completely own the low road if
he's gonna call people names he should
get it back a few weeks ago when it came
out that he lost more money than any
other American over a 10-year period I
suggested this Elizabeth Warren start
calling him broker hunters
we're alcoholics and it was just stupid
enough to go viral
rule number two is as far as the 2020
election goes the signup period is over
no more candidates we're full rule
number three Democrats must stand up to
Twitter catering to one contrived
outrage after another makes us look weak
just because woke babe 99 gets mad at
you doesn't mean the rest of America
gives a crap it's great your
gender-fluid but most of America things
gender-fluid is what comes out during a
wet dream
and for God's sake stop apologizing for
everything I know more about what
Democratic candidates have apologized
for but I know their stance on the
issues for I want all democrats to
memorize these two words message
discipline republicans win for two
reasons
teamwork and cheating and they are
really good at both democrats snipe and
[ __ ] at each other they like that
couple that's divorcing but they came to
the dinner party anyway
not republicans and that is something
else i have tried to impress upon the
candidates what about if the democrats
would call these trump tariffs which i
heard today largest tax increase really
since 1993 i can't the democrats do what
republicans do all get in a room and get
a talking point that then they all say
and call it the trump tax I want all you
[ __ ] running for
[Applause]
MSNBC sometimes shows a montage of a
dozen Republican saying the exact same
thing on a certain topic like gotcha
they all said the same thing that's not
a gotcha that's how you win you're
afraid that being on message makes you
look too much like a politician
let me tell you something the Millennial
vote will not be won through tweeting
and emojis or calling your budget
planned fire they can smell desperation
through their phones so just cut the
crap and just do you enough with the
videos people want an authority figure
as president not something looks like a
ten-year-old in a barber's chair Joe
Biden gets a colonoscopy every year if
he stays the front-runner we're gonna
have to livestream that from now on no
stunts no stunts like two weeks ago when
Congressman Steve Cohen brought KFC into
the session of Congress to remind
everyone that bill Barr was too chicken
get it to testify you know a picture is
worth a thousand words but none of those
words should be look at that idiot
if you want to bring something nasty and
greasy into a house hearing subpoenaed
on junior
you